all right so since I didn't actually add
a real-time footage part to any of my
episodes lately I just wanted to quickly
show off what the city looks like at the
moment and maybe talk a little bit about
what I want to do in the future I'm
sorry about the frame rates by the way
at least it might company to know that
it's been far worse it's actually pretty
good at the moment and I'm quite happy
to have 8 frames per second I'm sorry
about the seagulls - I still need get
anymore for that but yeah this is what
the city currently looks like the
episode took a little bit longer than I
expected since I really wanted to add a
bit of additional detailing not just the
path elements I mean the textures on the
roads and making sure that I got the
brick roads to get that more traditional
look going but also to make it look more
alive so adding little picnic places and
some quote unquote restaurants no actual
restaurants but making some small
classes look like there are restaurants
stuff like that to just make the city
feel more alive but yeah this is the
overall city at the moment this is the
star shape in its full glory I do have
to say this isn't entirely probably what
it's going to look like in the end since
I may very well change the way that the
everything pretty much around the star
shape looks because I haven't gone into
other houses around here because
historically I do want to get into maybe
some smaller older houses maybe a small
port with some boats really boats or
something that I should get into as well
and some sort of fields or parks around
it especially this corner over here is
something which I haven't done anything
with so far but um this should be the
center of this city
definitely the center is nearly finished
might add some extra details I've got a
slight issue with the scaling but
otherwise I'm quite happy with how it
turned out in the end and especially I
feel the street textures really helped
to make this city feel much more alive
the very basic idea of Willems thought
you can kind of see over here since it
has that sort of middle Boulevard over
here which is where I really wanted to
have the fanciest buildings and the very
I do have to say Amsterdam ish facades
around the side
it's the buildings and and this is my
main scaling issue which you can not see
too clearly in the time lapses but
probably see quite clearly in this
real-time part is that some of these
buildings are somewhat large and it's
not too big of an issue I do think
they're all rights in terms of scale the
only issue is that they're not quite
consistent as you can see these houses
over here are incredibly small self also
sort of gradually started removing these
houses from the city and replacing them
with these other ones but these are much
more like larger Amsterdam ich Hassan's
that you would find in larger cities and
not a small well star fort like this and
it's just a small touch I still feel
like overall especially this main sort
of area over here and it can now feel
really Dutch but it's not entirely the
idea of a star for its usually it's
almost like it's a larger city in the
shape over star forts but yeah overall
I'm quite happy with it and I think
there's actually some really cool detail
and overall atmosphere to the city as it
looks right now and I'll probably get
some more cinematic shots as the city is
completely finished and I'll make one
big video at the end of this complete
series I don't think that's something
I've talked about maybe I have in the
past but yeah that is definitely on my
planning and in that case I'll
definitely want to show off the city a
little bit more especially those little
roads that sort of go everywhere but
yeah that's it for today I think the
next time I'm gonna want to hand into
this area and maybe you start making
some forms but get into some different
stuff because otherwise quite frankly
it's gonna be pretty repetitive and
given that I'm on such a small map I
sort of want to try all sorts of
different things out so I might very
well start trying some tulip fields over
here as well some more grid pattern like
form since this really seems like an
area which might just be reclaimed from
a lake at some points in the recent
history and also what I think I wanna
get into is a golf course I think I'm
gonna want to place it over here but a
golf course in general is definitely
something that I'm gonna get to anyway
thank you guys for watching
and mmm goodbye I suppose all right so
with that out of the way I can finally
start a proper introduction to this
video welcome back to City skylines and
in this episode I'll be taking you
through a lot of detailing of the city
there's no specific thing which I'm
working on in this episode in the sense
that's and this is some language I may
want to explain a little I like to
divide my episodes into specific things
that I'm doing so for instance in one
episode I'd work on the University and
in another one I'd work on the stadium
area and Rio Yard but what sort of a
consequence of that is that I try to
fill the projects that I do into certain
time slots that I can fit into the
episodes and in that a lot of these
smaller stuff really gets like left
behind because it's really the small
stuff that I don't want to deal with in
those episodes and aren't really part of
the larger things that I want to do in
episodes but really are necessary to
make the entire city come together if it
were as a whole so that's something
which I actually wanted to tackle in
this episode a little bit and it
includes some of this rock work over
here with some foliage around this area
since I really still had this empty
field lying around over here and really
wanted to make it into a somewhat neat
little looking lake and also want to
work on some of the detailing in the
university as I said I would return to
at some point in the future when I built
the university and then there are like a
couple of smaller misc things like also
oh yeah redoing the the football stadium
that's actually a pretty big thing
so yeah it's generally making the city
come together a little bit more and
adding some detailing to it what I do
should what I do want to say probably
about this lake over here is that it's
not that Dutch there are a number of
things which I've been looking for in a
way to make these lakes look a little
bit more Dutch but one of the issues
that I really have with the water system
or had up to this point is that you
can't really get water in without having
the rocky slopes on the sides and you
can't really have it be very gentle into
the water without getting the sand on
the side of the water and realistically
it would be amazing to just have across
a slope go into the water
and this is also something where I
should explain something about this
series in general which is that I can't
build keys yet and I also can't work
with themes at this point in the series
because what's going on is that a couple
of weeks ago I really just played city
skylines pretty much 24/7 and got many
of these time lapses but I do want to
get them out in a more stable rates than
and more consistent than just spamming
out videos whenever I play the game a
lot and it really just depends on what I
want to play and I have to be quite
honest about that and at the moment I'm
not really playing the game as much
because I'm just not feeling like it and
at the time I had a lot of free time and
I was pretty much addicted to City
skylines so we still have a lot of stuff
that I have but I still need to get
through that or and I still need to
actually commentate and put all the
videos together or which I should also
do a little bit better of a job ad when
it comes to forgetting to insert these
little real-time parts and stuff like
that but that's really beside the point
the point is that there are certain
things that I would like to get to at
this point in the series but simply
can't because all these episodes are
already pre-recorded so I can't work
with the newest update stuff like keys
and at this point in time there weren't
really any themes yet either that I
could really use so yeah those those are
pretty much things to keep in mind that
said though I do have a bit of knowledge
about what the future episodes are going
to be about so I can actually reflect
back on what I said in the real-time
part I said I would work on a golf
course
and while I've tried it off-screen it
didn't really work out that well and I
really would rather have everything that
I do build make it somewhat realistic
and not try to push things to an
unrealistic look just to get certain
things in for instance I want to have
ditches but since there aren't really
any ditches that can very much look
convincingly touch I rather have no
ditches at all instead of having ditches
that could possibly break the immersion
of realism in this case and much like
that I really felt like the golf course
didn't come out good enough to have it
in the city even though I did sort of
like how it looked I just didn't
well with the rest of the city that said
I will actually have some flower fields
though they are absolutely a pain to
place so I'm not really sure how much
more I'll get of those and at some point
in the future people have actually
hinted towards this I'll actually be
building a theme park but that's really
far in the future that is the episode
that I've just recently recorded which
is at this point in time many episodes
are held in the actual series all right
now something else which I also wanted
to do in this video is place lots of
tree lines something which I always used
to joke about in streams whenever I was
streaming this is that it would pretty
much be 50% three line placements and
it's very true you do see many of them
in the Netherlands not as many perhaps
as I'm getting around here but
especially around the newer areas you do
see a lot of very neatly placed lines of
trees that is windbreakers around farm
areas but also very ornamental tree
lines around the city areas so that's
something which I really wanted to have
here and there as well and definitely
where I didn't have them yet
I wanted to add some three lines and
there were still also some unfinished
parts here in there like this very small
almost not so urban area anymore but
it's still really close to the city
itself so I didn't want to figure I
didn't want to fill that up with some
houses and there was also this little
bicycle bridge which I'm actually really
happy about how it turn out in the end I
didn't really have anything fancy to
work with so it's mostly in the shape
that I wanted to do it but it's it's
still something which i think is pretty
cool even though the bicycle bridges in
the Netherlands as applauded as they
probably are in the rest of the world
don't really work out that well for
cyclists and a regular roundabout is a
lot easier but regardless also that you
could probably see a major traffic jam
right now and that's one of the issues
which I don't think I can really get rid
of anymore ever since
snowfall got released and traffic
plus-plus doesn't work anymore I needed
to put traffic plus plus on ghost mode
to be able to look the city again and
traffic plus plus b2 doesn't work and if
I play without traffic plus plus the
game also doesn't load so I really
needed to load the city
because of that I actually lost some
functionality especially the AI
functionality which was pretty important
and because of that traffic is quite
broken and I might find him the way to
fix this at some point in the future if
anybody knows about a way to actually go
about doing that that would be amazing
but at the moment
pretty much the vehicle sometimes don't
de-spawn whenever they get stuck in a
certain place and which causes create
which causes giant traffic jams all over
the place and in general the AI is just
not as good as I was hoping it to be
when I built the road layouts in the
city so traffic jams are a bit of an
issue at this point in time though then
again my stance on traffic jams is
pretty much that the most important
thing for the road layouts I think is to
make it realistic and inspired by the
touch road layouts and not so much to
make it actually functional on the game
because there is much more traffic in
the game than there would realistically
be in a real city of the same size which
is something that I've definitely
commented on about but it's something
which I don't try to think of too much
when I'm actually laying down the road
just because I'd rather just work on the
aesthetics rather than trying to get
this thing to be as well-functioning as
it can from a gameplay standpoint now I
also wanted to really detail the
university a little bit more this was
one of the things which was really
negative me at this point in time and
also something which really stuck out
here was with all the extreme rain like
reflection which I'm glad actually got
turned down a little bit in the latest
update it's something which I saw the
part that wasn't entirely finished yet
but I also needed many more trees around
that area just to add what I had said
when I built the university I would do
at some point in the future add some
liveliness to it to make it come alive a
little bit more and not feel so dead and
the most easy way to really go about
doing so is adding some more trees which
generally makes something look a lot
less cold and I didn't do much else
beside that just some simple path
elements I believe and a little bit of
Park bushes and things like that but
aside from that it's nothing really too
special just dancing up the foliage and
adding some ornamental foliage here and
there to make the general University
campus look
little bit more appealing than just one
giant plaza of concrete and buildings
out of bricks that's basically the idea
behind it and another thing which I
really needed to do which was quite a
disaster over here is sort of fix those
gravel roads because that was really
ugly sight to look at which I've said it
in the last video but it's actually a
bigger issue in this case the fact that
I can't work with traffic plus plus
anymore for the time being actually also
means that I can't use the pedestrian
roads anymore so I don't have the
concrete pedestrian roads anymore and
they've all been replaced automatically
by these gravel roads which are for
farmland so don't work out quite as well
and these are all basically going to be
the one by one or on the one tile roads
which I actually quite liked and are
quite a bit more realistic to I think
but it's something which I did have to
keep in mind when I got back to the
University to sort of fix that and also
add some smaller little plazas and
relaxation areas here and there just to
make it all feel a little bit more like
it's actually a coherent campus and not
just a collection of buildings which is
really blocked down in a certain way but
with no way to actually connect the
buildings and make them feel like one
whole basically so that's really what I
wanted to do with the campus it's
nothing really special but just a
general little makeover of the campus to
make it look look a little bit more neat
though of course certain things like
little tweaking and adding some small
details here and there on the campus
which I may want to return to in the
future but if I do stuff like that I do
prefer to do it just off time-lapses
because it's not a very time-consuming
thing and it doesn't translate too well
in the time-lapse concept I think which
is really best at betraying a sort of
progress as you see in the episode which
is really why I want to focus on major
builds rather than small details and
tweaks in time lapses and another thing
which I wanted to add over here is of
course make the station area look a
little bit better because it was just
absolute [ __ ] and well before this time
it wasn't really anything so that was
something which I needed to get back to
and
also wanted to actually go back and make
a little bus station because that's
something which I didn't really have
properly yet but that's something which
you'll see later on in this video I
really just wanted to focus on the area
around the station a little bit not
dress it up too much and I also have to
say there's no main transportation hub
for this campus or anything special like
that just a very simple station in which
I quickly go in there and a small bus
stop I may still want to get a bus stop
on the other side of the campus not just
because it's something which is of
course quite handy since the campus
isn't that small and I really hate when
a campus has to use one bus stop which
is the case for the Rotterdam campus
which I have to go to which can be kind
of annoying if you're in a building on
the other side of campus and the bus
stop is way too far away from that
building so yeah it's just something
which I may want to get back to in the
future as well now of course I wanted to
redo this station placing down the
station is something which I did
off-camera just because I wanted to go
through a couple of stations I mean what
am I saying I'm talking about this
stadium that that is the football
stadium I was going through a couple of
stadiums in the workshop and I really
just picked this one because it's best
size-wise it's a bit of an annoying
model since it also has that road
sticking out there and other stuff and
something else which happen over here as
you can see is that very sudden jump I
think I lost somewhere between like an
hour to two hours of footage over here
due to a crash of fraps for some reason
which was rather annoying but I
basically built the station in this time
as well as the parking area around the
station you can see it littering a
little bit there with the cross which is
something that I don't really know what
causes it but basically every time I
place an object around the perimeter of
the stadium it's sort of glitches like
that and has a random grass patches
coming out and at some point in time
that'll fix itself so that's no big
problem but basically what I did around
that area was a lot of detailing redoing
the parking lot and basically making
sure I could integrate the station as
well as I could into the area
because that's one of the main issues I
had with this particular model is even
though I do like this station and why do
I keep things and how do I keep saying
station I do like the stadium and it's
quite a bit small and then they come now
which is of course a lot better for the
scale of the city but I sort of wanted
to work around the roads that it gave
you and that little pedestrian bridge
which it actually came with which turned
out to not be that big of a problem
because I already had a pedestrian
bridge running over the highway so I
could actually make use of that but I
wanted to make sure that it was actually
integrated into the rest of the area as
seamlessly as possible and without
seeming too much like the model actually
came with those roads so that was really
the idea behind that I also wanted to do
redo some of the foliage over here which
wasn't too necessary I wanted to redo
some of the foliage because I felt it
wasn't dense enough in this area and
wanted to add a little bit of density to
it but also wanted to redo a couple of
trees because this was still the time
when the trees in the game since the
latest snowfall updates I believe were
looking very sick and almost lost all
their leaves which wasn't really great
so I wanted to replace all of those but
by this time it's already been fixed
again so that wasn't extremely handy but
it's still something I've wanted to do
and also some general extra detailing of
the railroad which also I think works
quite well with the new lute which I
have something I haven't addressed yet
is that yeah I do also have a new lute
where they liked classic as well which I
do like a little bit more than the old
lutes it's something which I had to get
used to a little bit I'm not sure if
it's really more realistic might be a
little less so but it's a little more
saturated and a little bit bit more
contrast the old one was perhaps a
little bit too bright and it didn't have
the colours come out so much so I do
like this one a little bit more to look
at and it's also something which I find
in general as more fun to add details to
and go a little bit more colorful and
detailed with the foliage so that's also
one of the reasons why I think I really
went back and redid a lot of the foliage
as well simply because I think it looks
a bit better with this lute too and
besides that
I also wanted to take care of the
waterfronts the best that I felt I could
at this point in time without being able
to get cross or wooden River sites I
figured might as well add some extra
rocks here in there and some grass to
sort of look like read which does the
job I guess from a distance but isn't
too great from very closer but I really
liked anything more than just a rocky
facade at this point in time I think so
yeah that's that I also wanted to add
some small pebbles around these pokey
facades there are those textures that
you can put on the ground and one of
them is actually I don't know who made
it so I'm sorry about not giving credit
for it but you can actually blend those
pebbles really well I feel with the
rocky taxis that the games that the game
come to it and have those textures blend
a little bit more with the grass rather
than having just grass and suddenly the
olden box which is actually something
which I've really lights as well and in
general I just wanted to add a lot more
foliage over here it's something which I
should have punched myself for in
looking back at it because I just used
trees that are way too LOD heavy so this
may come back at me at some point in the
future and maybe I shouldn't have used
these trees because they're so extremely
LOD heavy but it's something which I
really wanted to do because I'd like to
look at them and I can still go on with
the city for quite a while I'm still
planning to at least finish it to the
point that it has a general decent area
of realistic touch looking land somewhat
I feel around it and that's still my
plan and that's still I'm going to try
to do it
so there's still quite a few episodes
ahead but yeah that's it for this
episode so thank you guys for watching
and so far but I do have to say I do
still have a small well cinematic camera
parts in this video in which I'll
finally be able to actually show off
what the new stadium looks like without
having that time lapse and also a couple
more shots of the Inner City because I
just left that stuff out of the last
episode and I actually still have those
lying around on my computer as well so
thank you guys for watching and see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you